maintenant François Léotard
bonsoir connaissez Marie Laforêt Titeuf
Joey Starr et mon ami Elisa Thauvette
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle pour parler de votre livre en
premier alors
vous connaissez Joey Starr
je l'ai subi en juin 96 lorsque
marcchiani le préfet du Var obtient que
NTM soit déprogrammée du festival dans
le Var je suis le seul à l'avoir défendu
vous protestez je suis d'accord
la vraie raison pour laquelle quand même
je serre la main au jeune homme qui est
à côté de moi c'est que c'est que je
suivais son frère respectait beaucoup
testé c'est vrai François Léotard a
protesté mais j'ai l'impression de le
croire sincère c'est vrai il a protesté
de toute façon marcanique c'est pas son
copain donc de toute façon tout ce que
j'ai marqué
voilà c'est un copain Pasqua Marc Annie
mais 5 mois plus tard quand même un
petit peu varié vous avez estimé que la
condamnation quand même était pas si
mauvaise que ça et voilà
il y a ma musique et moi et c'est deux
choses quand même bien
réconciliez-vous puisque c'est une
soirée la main ouais très bien alors
François leotard vous avez arrêté
définitivement la politique
il a arrêté il a dit j'ai fait le tour
j'arrête et fin décembre 2001 vous avez
été nommé inspecteur général des
finances nommé en Conseil des ministres
par Chirac et accepté par Jospin il a
pas arrêté il a abandonné tous ces
mandats politiques je crois que le
dernier que je vais abandonner c'est
député du Var vous étiez élu sans arrêt
depuis des lustres depuis 25 ans et vous
avez arrêté donc maintenant il a plus de
fonction politique François le Tarn est
plus un homme politique on va voir c'est
un des finances justement alors
qu'est-ce que c'est
expliquez-nous François quand j'ai fait
les nages j'étais je suis rentré dans la
préfectorale après j'étais élu pendant
25 ans et là je retourne à
l'administration administration donc
c'est pas la même chose quand on est
dans la vie politique on est élu la
l'administration on est nommé et c'est
pas mal le pays en même temps
ça gagne alors on peut le dire aussi
puisqu'on dit tout ça gagne 60 000
balles par mois inspecteur des finances
je suis pas là j'ai commencé il y a un
mois j'en suis pas là mais qu'est-ce
qu'on alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand
on est inspecteur la douane de
Saint-Malo
on arrive on discute avec les gens on
regarde ce qui se passe on regarde si il
travaille bien s'ils arrivent à l'heure
le matin si voilà ça fera bon ça donc
aujourd'hui François Léotard vous êtes
soumis un devoir de réserve on peut dire
quand même que vous êtes plutôt
favorable à Chirac à Beyrou
ouais je dirais même pas ça je veux dire
que j'ai des convictions depuis 30 ans
j'ai jamais changé et je suis pas à
gauche il faut dire les choses de façon
négative ça c'est vrai mais voilà je
m'arrête là
voilà et puis il y a des centristes qui
sont pour Beyrout d'accords comme 12
Blazy par exemple alors en tous les cas
François Léotard
a déclaré il y a 20 ans donc c'est pas
un propos de circonstances c'était en 82
vous avez déclaré j'ai toujours eu le
sentiment que la littérature c'était
vrai c'était le monde réel et que le
reste était faux donc c'est pas nouveau
hein et pourtant à l'époque que vous
avez déclaré ça vous étiez en plein dans
la politique c'est une époque était très
importante pour vous et si votre père
André Léotard qui vous a branché sur la
littérature il vous disait votre père
une journée passée sans lire est une
journée perdue il fallait qu'on lise un
livre par jour voilà François Le auteur
j'ai déjà publié 8 livres mais c'est
votre premier roman c'est comment on
fait
Joe montre lui
il peut faire que ça attention 1 2 3
de François Léotard s'appelle la couleur
des femmes c'est chez Grasset alors
François notaire pourquoi la couleur des
femmes parce que le narrateur qui est
pas qui est pas levain qui est le
narrateur la personne qui parle avec un
jeu dit quand il voit une femme il
connaît tout de suite sa couleur il
devine tout de suite sa couleur il parle
des femmes violettes il parle des femmes
roses des par les femmes
bleues celles qui l'aime et celle qu'il
rencontre pour la première fois enfin si
j'ose dire il est beaucoup plus âgé
qu'elle c'est une jeune Palestinienne
elle est elle est brune et il dit tous
tes bras en elle sont son regard son
visage son corps et et là une espèce de
autour d'elle comme un silence qui est
lui-même brun et il sent la couleur des
femmes il dit j'ai connu des femmes
vertes qui étaient comme des prairies au
bord de la mer et et il a un sens de la
il aime les femmes et il aime les femmes
il les connaît par cette couleur quelle
qu'elle exprime alors le pitch qu'est-ce
qui se passe pourquoi il rigole
c'est beaucoup plus rigoles attends-nous
Marie on arrive
franchement
je vais essayer le pitch comme on dit
ici donc c'est Roméo et Juliette hein
c'est David qui est fils de Rabat qui
est une espèce d'eternel étudiante qui
rencontre Sonia qui est violoniste
d'origine palestinienne ils sont le
contraire l'un de l'autre et ils vont
s'aimer jusqu'au jour où elle décide
brutalement de rompre voilà alors
pourquoi avoir pris un héros juif
j'ai toujours je me suis engagé dans la
vie politique à cause de la Shoah parce
que j'ai considéré que c'était ce qui
avait dans l'histoire du monde dans
l'histoire humaine ce qui avait de pire
et que c'était hier et que donc
l'histoire l'idée du progrès lui-même
elle est une idée qui m'est assez
étrangère je pense que que l'homme
l'humanité l'humain peut continuer
aujourd'hui à torturer à tuer à fusiller
à pendre François Léotard ce livre parle
de la guerre et vous qui vous vivez en
héros romantique est-ce que ça va vous a
manqué finalement de pas avoir pu vivre
d'une guerre je suis dans une génération
où on voulait tous être Jean Moulin
ouais bon on se disait au fond c'est il
y a quelque chose si de nouveau ça
revenait c'est ça qu'il faudrait faire
puis voilà on est on est arrivé après la
guerre d'Algérie en fait et donc Dieu
merci pour pour la France pour ce pays
il y a pas eu de guerre dans la
génération à laquelle j'appartiens dieu
merci bon moi j'ai pas connu proprement
parler comme ministre vous pensez que la
politique en tant pis c'est quelque
chose d'assez superficiel finalement et
que ça vous a manqué ça de pas avoir je
pense que vous avez demandé allez on
Macédoine par exemple oui oui parce que
parce que là il y avait de nouveau le
tragique et que je savais très bien pour
être allé souvent à Bosnie à Sarajevo
que ça pouvait recommencer là et que
tout ce qu'on avait fait comme effort
avec les blessés les morts on a eu 600
blesser nous en Yougoslavie les Français
j'accompagnais chacun d'entre eux qui
étaient amputé qui était défigurée etc
et je crois qu'il bon il fallait éviter
que ça continue ou plutôt que ça
recommence son sens inverse ça s'est
arrêté d'ailleurs ça s'est arrêté on a
réussi
alors en fait François Léotard le David
le héros de votre roman écrit l'histoire
25 ans après les faits et c'est là qu'il
part rencontrer cette Layla qui est la
sœur donc de Sonia qu'il avait beaucoup
aimé à l'époque avant leur rupture
il lui fait un enfant et elle meurt dans
un attentat contre un bus
et est-ce que finalement le fait d'avoir
été propalestinien dans votre jeunesse
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui vous a
ramené vers ça que je me souviens de
toutes les guerres qui se sont passées
là-bas à chaque fois j'ai traduit mon
mon admiration pour l'État d'Israël
chaque fois parce que je considérais que
c'était un peuple menacé et je trouve
que maintenant effectivement le conflit
d'aujourd'hui est terrible parce que
chacun a raison et comment départager
des gens qui se chassent l'un l'autre de
la même terre et presque de la des mêmes
racines qui sont tous des enfants
d'Abraham veut dire c'est c'est
extrêmement difficile de dire voilà cela
en raison cela en tort et et je pensais
que l'amour entre un être entre deux
êtres humains une petite arabe et un
juif cet amour-là pouvait transcender
les langues les cultures les religions
les histoires l'humus l'épaisseur des
histoires et et je pense que c'est
encore possible je pense que quand un
être humain aime une autre personne il
peut traverser toute une série
d'obstacles et que malheureusement la
logique de l'histoire c'est la guerre et
c'est de les empêcher de s'aimer
alors on va parler un peu de vous parce
que finalement je me rends compte qu'on
vous connaît assez mal
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes en 1942 il y a bientôt
60 ans famille de 7 enfants dans votre
frère Philippe Léotard à qui le livre
est dédié alors quand vous étiez
ministre de la Défense il disait moi je
suis ministre de la Défense ça définit
assez bien le personnage
tout est dit alors vous êtes Corse par
votre mère et vous descendez de la sœur
de Charlemagne ça c'est vous qui me
prenez mon père s'appelle Charlemagne
aussi il y avait une sœur de Charlemagne
qui est parti évangéliser la Corse et
votre père ça j'espère que vous le savez
votre père est parents du clown Léotard
vous le savez ça il y avait un Léotard
qui était clown qui était l'inventeur
et alors
c'est vrai et le et ce clown Léotard a
été l'inventeur du justaucorps pour les
danseuses et en anglais en anglais on
dit toujours Richard
alors votre père François Léotard était
maire de Fréjus il y a eu en 1959 à
Fréjus une grande catastrophe qui la
rupture du barrage de Malpassé ce qui
fait que toute la région a été inondée
il y a eu beaucoup de morts votre père a
été calomnier on a parlé de détournement
de fonds publics destiné à la
reconstruction de la région est-ce que
ça aurait pas pu ça vous guérir de la
politique est-ce que finalement
voyons comment votre père était
calomnier pourquoi vous êtes pas dit la
politique c'est de la merde j'y vais pas
quoi c'était l'inverse c'est marrant
parce que mes origines Corses ont fait
que quand il est mort je me suis dit
cela ceux qui ont fait ça je vais les
avoir
et c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est bizarre je trouve que la vengeance
est un très beau sentiment
son côté Corse non on nous a tous
enseigné que c'était pas bien moi je
trouve c'est très bien tu es d'accord
je suis assez d'accord bien alors
vous étiez PS sur 68 vous jetiez avec
votre frère des pots de fleurs sur les
CRS et des choses oui c'est marrant
parce que
on dirait que vous avez pas été jeune à
ces moments
oui mais c'est vrai ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a un moment où la
générosité la volonté de révolte
l'esprit de révolte l'emporte sur le
reste quand vous êtes jeune et que vous
êtes pas révolté alors vous êtes droit
des cons hein je veux dire que si quand
on a 20 ans on n'est pas en révolte
contre une société contre escalade
injuste de mal foutue dire c'est assez
bizarre et moi j'étais comme ça c'est
vrai j'étais comme ça
que j'ai changé parce que j'ai pensé
qu'il fallait que ça se société là elle
marche elle fonctionne qu'il fallait la
faire fonctionner ce qui prouve à quel
point vous étiez en quête à cette à cet
âge-là cette époque là c'est qu'à l'âge
de 22 ans vous partez dans un monastère
et sous le nom de Frère Honorat vous
devenez un moine bénédictin au couvent
de la pierre qui vit on se lève la nuit
on fait des prières en pleine nuit donc
ça prouve quand même que cette époque là
vous aviez un vrai un vrai désir
d'absolu et de silence oui parce que
beau dans la vie monastique c'est le
silence vous me dites rien vous parlez
pas et pendant un an j'ai pas parlé
ça fait du bien ça c'est fabuleux
alors voilà mais en revenant en fait
quand même les nappes et vous êtes
toujours de gauche parce que vous créez
la première section syndicale de la CFDT
Alena en 74 vous votez pour le président
Mitterrand alors pourquoi après vous
êtes devenus de droite pour réussir non
c'est Giscard je vais vous dire c'est
marrant quand Giscard a commencé sa vie
politique enfin par l'élection
présidentielle j'ai eu le sentiment
j'étais pas le seul on était nombreux
puisqu'il a été élu elle pensait qu'il
était moderne il apportait dans la vie
politique française qui était très
archaïque des sentiments de modernité
des éléments de modernité c'était
d'ailleurs l'avortement avec Simone Veil
etc et pour les jeunes le droit de vote
pour les jeunes fait beaucoup de choses
sa façon d'être son comportement
c'est-à-dire et ça je reconnais à l'âge
que j'avais à ce moment là ça m'a séduit
puis j'ai les suivi après pendant
jusqu'à maintenant vous avez été
extrêmement virulent en 81 quand la
gauche est arrivée au pouvoir des quatre
ministres communistes alors que l'URSS
existait encore c'est pas comme
maintenant et puis il y a eu ce qu'on
appelle la bande à Léo ça a été un petit
peu le crapogée avec Madelin Longué
douffia qui lui aussi d'ailleurs a
arrêté la politique complètement vous
êtes deux sur quatre pratiquement 3 sur
4 et lancer l'époque on a parlé du temps
des quadras il y avait Michel Noir il y
avait toute cette bande de gens Carignan
et ça a pas marché pourquoi vous êtes
planté parce que vous vouliez renouveler
la vie politique à l'époque il y avait
des volontés de réformes ce qui me
frappe le plus dans la vie politique
française c'est c'est comment dire son
caractère fermé c'est à dire que vous
avez pas le système américain vous
faites pas plus que deux mandats et
demanda au maximum de 4 ans puis après
vous allez dans une banque dans une
entreprise éventuellement vous revenez
en France vous avez des gens de 75 ans
qui continue à se présenter et qui sont
là depuis 35 40 ans est-ce que vous avez
pas été à la hauteur de vos ambitions ou
c'est la France qui n'a pas été à la
hauteur de vos ambitions et je crois que
j'ai mis 25 ans à savoir ou deviner que
j'aimais pas le pouvoir c'est très
étrange il y a des gens comme ça qui
découvrent tardivement qu'ils sont
véritablement mais je crois qu'au fond
le pouvoir s'accorderont Satus sa bougie
ça démolit et voilà et puis j'ai mis du
temps à comprendre ça et vous étiez mon
frère tout à l'heure je crois que c'est
lui qui avait raison au fond
[Musique]
je crois que moi c'est probablement lui
qui a raison c'est tout j'ai eu plein de
problèmes vous êtes opposé à Pasqua
c'est l'affaire du charter des 101
maliens vous étiez contre
deuxième problème en 95 vous choisissez
Balladur et pachirac mauvaise pioche
vous étiez peut-être aussi trop en titre
Front national pour le parti républicain
qui est finalement un parti où il y a
pas mal de gens qui sont fait pas
d'extrême droite mais bien à droite
quand même on voit ce qui est devenu
démocratie libérale et puis vous avez vu
aussi des affaires sur le dos pas mal
d'affaires le mur de votre propriété de
Fréjus sur lequel on a beaucoup glosé et
pour lesquelles il y a jamais eu un seul
une seule condamnation du racisme sinon
je viendrai pas devant vous au contraire
en tous les cas vous adversaires qui ont
été condamnés pour diffamation les
Duplessis il y a eu la feriane Piat qui
a été assassiné alors on vous a
carrément accusé d'avoir été à l'origine
du meurtre avec Godin c'est la fameuse
affaire de l'encornet de trottinette et
finalement là aussi vous avez attaqué
pour diffamation et la plus grande et
deux auteurs du bouquin ont été
condamnés c'est la plus forte
condamnation pénale quand j'ai pu
obtenir sur des journalistes enfin des
gens qui se qualifient le journaliste un
million de franc S
et puis là vous avez toujours une
affaire sur le dos quand même qui est
pas réglé c'est l'affaire de l'achat du
siège du parti républicain rue de
Constantine et une banque italienne qui
l'a acheté et qui dit l'argent que j'ai
mis dans l'achat de ce siège du parti
républicain rue de Constantine monsieur
nous l'a apporté en coupure de 500
balles l'instruction a été close la
demande du parquet et c'est un vrai
semblable d'ailleurs parce que ça
commence à bien faire ça fait maintenant
5 6 ou 7 ans je sais plus que on attend
que de l'affaire soit terminée soit
close et ça vous êtes devant des
situations qui sont insupportables pour
n'importe quelle justiciable là on est
entre nous il y a une banque italienne
qui achète le siège du parti républicain
rue de Constantine cette banque dit le
pognon nous qu'on a donné pour acheter
on nous l'a apporté en coupure de 500
les mecs du parti républicains disent
oui chez les fonds secrets qu'on a gardé
à l'époque de Matignon c'est une
décision qui a été prise à 30 30 autour
d'une table des romans et s'il y a 32
voyous 30 gangsters ça se sait et moi
j'étais le vraiment probablement celui
qui savait le moins comment ça s'est
passé puis vous n'êtes pas juge si mes
souvenirs sont bons alors tout ça je
l'ai dit au juge et à mon avis ça va
bien
démocratie libérale a attaqué les gens
voilà c'est pour ça que nous ça nous met
un doute parce que si madame je suis
solidaire de l'achat de ce siège mais il
se trouve que lui il transforme le nom
c'est les jugements rendus en 3 minutes
à la télévision et alors une des raisons
français doit faire une des raisons de
votre retrait du jeu politique c'est
aussi vous ennuis de santé parce que
vous étiez un marathonien Amérique et un
jour on vous fait un triple pontage
coronarien c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pas
faire de jogging si j'ai beaucoup aimé
ça c'est mais peut-être pas en faire
trop puis c'est le stress la seule fois
vous avez un stress vous avez la veine
qui se qui se resserre
et donc donc ça ça la langue ça je
pourrais récupérer le vélo qui est
là-bas après là c'est suite Drucker il
faut que tu files de la presse
c'est pour Michael blanc le mec qui est
en tôle
est-ce que vous avez pas été victime
finalement d'un désenchantement
progressif
quelquefois on comment dire on a on a
envie de d'abord on a envie d'avoir
plusieurs vies dans sa vie moi je trouve
ça bien de suivre ses désirs de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire et je pense pas
qu'il y a une seule vie donc ça j'en ai
un peu fait le tour c'est vrai les gens
sont plus ou moins bien comme bon et
donc voilà j'ai envie de connaître
d'autres gens de faire d'autres choses
de me balader de de pouvoir de pouvoir
être considéré comme un citoyen
ordinaire ça c'est formidable
en tout cas beaucoup plus heureux mais
ça c'est vrai
François Léotard est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir raté votre vie non
[Musique]
si c'était à refaire je referai à peu
près pareil à peu près la même chose
on rallume
François la couleur des femmes son
premier roman c'est chez Grassé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant on va faire un
anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
français notaire si vous étiez un défaut
vous seriez quel défaut
[Musique]
je suis myope c'est formidable quand on
est myope vous êtes dans la dans la même
pièce que Didier Schuller et vous le
voyez pas ça peut aider en politique
si vous étiez un accident
un accident naturel peut-être j'ai rêvé
d'être un raz-de-marée parce que la mer
on lui fait ça va aller tellement de
choses
si vous étiez une perversion
le voyeur le voyeurisme j'aimerais bien
rentrer voir les gens comme ça comme ils
vivent dans la tête dans leur tête mais
aussi de chez eux ça j'adore ça une
mouche si vous étiez une guerre
et la norme elle débarquement en
Normandie ça c'était très il y a eu des
Français qui ont débarquons l'a oublié
des fusiés marins qui ont débarqué en
Normandie les premiers les premiers sur
la plage de Rivabella et beaucoup sont
morts c'était très beau si vous étiez
une arme
un Opinel ou un truc comme ça pour le
figatel couteau Corse alors un supplice
un très beau supplice que j'ai en tête
qui est celui de Tantale mais il est
dans l'eau et puis l'eau arrive jusque
là il a soif je propose qu'on remplace
l'eau par du vent de Romanet ou par un
Pétrus un très bon Bordeaux c'est une
cicatrice
je vais pas vous la montrer mais je suis
ouvert de là jusque là
je l'aime bien je la touche si vous y
étiez une vous seriez qui moi
j'aime pas le mot parce que j'ai jamais
dit ça à une femme mais
c'est bien dommage pourtant
chacun son truc mais j'ai jamais dit ça
une femme jamais
on est tous comme ça autant normal voilà
je pensais je pensais à Simone Signoret
dans dans Les Diaboliques pas la
personne la crise le personnage ou
Madame de Merteuil dans la maison
dangereuses je veux dire une femme qui
fait des trucs extraordinaire mon
diabolique mais qui arrive à faire tuer
son amant par la maîtresse de cet amour
c'est génial si vous étiez un dictateur
quelle dictateur seriez-vous
j'aime pas ça je pense vous allez
Charlie Chaplin quand il joue avec il
s'appelle le dictateur avec un ballon
qui a le monde c'est pas drôle si vous
êtes j'aurais voulu que on pose ces
questions là mais on peut te les poser
tiens bon va te la poser à toi la
prochaine si vous étiez une torture
avec la reine d'Angleterre
moi je m'appelle resto de mites ou alors
si j'étais une torture je m'appellerai
cocaïne par exemple voilà ah oui ça
c'est une vraie réponse on va dire
c'est pour ça qu'il fallait au lieu des
questions en bois de tout à l'heure là
machin là
un dictateur ou autre
si vous étiez un terroriste vous seriez
qui comme terroriste un mec qui roule en
Ferrari
et qui s'arrête pas au cas où vous étiez
une injure vous seriez quel injure on va
manger la culotte à ta vieille
si vous étiez une perversion
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes en forme là si vous étiez un
vice un vice
un vice je dirais comment il s'appelle
l'autre était Michael Michael
c'est le Morning Live sur M6 tous les
matins voilà mais mais c'est même pas
pour lui faire quoi que ce soit si je
suis pas démago moi c'est vraiment parce
que je le crois il a mal quelque part si
vous étiez une arme si j'étais une arme
nique ta mère mais avec pas chez Sony et
si vous étiez une mort
tu as un truc bien horrible la tête dans
une baignoire
parce que on veut on veut que je dise où
je vais mon magot d'accord
ça quoi d'accord ouais
ça franchement ça c'est pire que de te
brûler les pieds ou parce que parce que
le gaz ou des choses comme ça on a un
moment d'inconscience et ainsi de suite
quoi là c'est vraiment c'est
on peut te la serrer et le corps humain
est trop bien fait c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné tu perds conscience mais
quand on te noie
c'est claustrophobie c'est même ceux qui
savent pas ce que c'est après à ce
moment
François si vous étiez une mort
dans mon lit je cite une mort qui est
très belle un moment il raconte la mort
de Kafka elle est très belle parce qu'il
demande de la morphine il est il est il
est en train de mourir c'est de la mort
luxueux attends il demande de la
morphine l'équipe on a pas où il dit non
il y en a pas il dit cette phrase
extraordinaire dit tu es moi sinon vous
êtes un assassin voilà
couleur des femmes c'est chez Grasser
mesdames messieurs ce n'est pas son
premier livre mais c'est son premier
roman
François merci d'être venu je vais vous
laisser filer merci beaucoup à bientôt
merci à chacun
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu